jamais où voit l'amendement 13 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est donc
pas adopté passons à l'article premier a
j'ai une demande de prise de parole
madame Laurence Muller Brown
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues en tant que sénatrice
alsacienne je ne peux que regretter les
décisions prises depuis une dizaine
d'années concernant
nos centrales nucléaires et partout
particulièrement celle de Fessenheim qui
aurait pu être maintenu si notamment
nous n'avions pas fait le choix de
sacrifier la souveraineté énergétique
française aux intérêts économiques et
politiques de nos voisins allemands les
deux réacteurs étaient en effet jugés
par l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire parmi
les meilleurs du parc nucléaire français
tant au plan de la sûreté qu'au plan
environnemental je rappelle que 700
millions d'euros ont été investis dans
la centrale peu de temps avant la ferme
faire la fermeture pardon pour la
maintenir au plus haut niveau et qu'elle
comptait 3000 emplois directs et
indirects pour compenser les pertes
d'activité et d'emplois et rendent cette
décision acceptable auprès des habitants
et des élus locaux un projet
franco-allemand est sorti du chapeau
dans l'urgence une société d'économie
mixte a été lancée sans anticipation ni
réflexion et ses soldés par un échec
elle a été dissoute sans avoir mené un
seul projet et après avoir coûté un
million d'euros
enfin les projets de reconversion du
site qui ont été annoncés dont le fameux
Technocentre d'EDF et pour lesquels le
président de la République a promis 20
millions d'euros dans son discours à
Belfort le 18 r février 2022 sont restés
bloqués au stade de l'affichage qu'en
est-il madame la ministre au moment où
vous envisagez la fermeture d'autres
sites nucléaires le cas de Fessenheim a
de quoi nous inquiéter des élus locaux
n'ont pas été écoutées les habitants ont
été méprisés et leurs promesses n'ont
pas été honorées alors je me félicite
que le texte du Sénat s'inscrivent enfin
dans une stratégie globale avec des
perspectives de planification
afin de ne pas reproduire de telles
décisions brutales incohérentes et
contre les intérêts des territoires
merci
chers collègues Monsieur François
bonhomme
merci madame le Président de monsieur le
rapporteur on peut toujours dire qu'il
ne s'agit par ce texte que de
débroussailler le terrain administratif
et juridique en attendant une feuille de
route et la relance formelle du
nucléaire avec des centrales de
nouvelles génération et la
reconstitution d'un parc performant mais
mon analyse vous avez déjà nous pouvons
dire que à ce stade vous avez participé
à s'aborder notre industrie nucléaire
certes le sabordage a été initié lancé
par François Hollande et le président
public ce point de vue n'en a été que le
continuateur mais cette situation
aujourd'hui nous oblige à reconstituer
notre filière nucléaire pour entamer un
point de reconstructure de
reconstruction et cela dans la
précipitation car tout cela va être long
coûteux mais nous n'avons pas le choix
la situation et la crise que nous
traversons est bien fait et bien l'effet
de la mise en œuvre des choix et des
orientations stratégiques qui ont été
fait il y a plus de 10 ans voilà ce qui
se passe quand les orientations
stratégiques ont été mauvaises et qui
ont prévalu lors de la PPE 2015 et 2019
voilà ce qui se passe quand on se laisse
intimider par le dogmatisme qui
aujourd'hui se heurte à une réalité
douloureuse de la crise énergétique et
qui arrive en fin quand on se laisse
intoxiqué par l'Allemagne dans tous les
sens du terme qui fait la leçon tout en
faisant tourner à plein c'est centrales
à charbon ce texte est la première étape
de revirement que vous avez vous
obstinez encore appelé anticipation et
en accélération comme si c'est un
simplement d'un changement de rythme
alors que nous devons prendre une
nouvelle orientation
et vous faites mis de découvrir que la
production d'électricité nucléaire doit
être la colonne vertébrale de notre
modèle énergétique pourtant les
conséquences aujourd'hui sont en grande
partie les conséquences de vos choix du
passé perte de capacité de notre
production énergétique faisant de notre
pays pour la première fois à
l'importateur net d'électricité de nos
voisins européens produite avec du gaz
et du charbon vulnérabilité structurelle
de notre système d'approvisionnement
explosion des coûts subis par les
collectivités ménages entreprises
dépenses budgétaire considérable et
malgré tout insuffisante pour amortir le
choc inflationniste dégradation de notre
solde commercial et vous avez
l'impudence Madame le Ministre de vous
féliciter du succès de votre plan de
sobriété il faut beaucoup d'estomac pour
dire cela
[Musique]
le président
merci beaucoup monsieur
madame Angèle Préville
merci Madame le présidente madame les
ministres mes chers collègues devant et
je tiens à reprendre enfin à prendre la
parole pour évoquer ce que mes collègues
ont évoqué par ailleurs devant le choix
crucial d'avenir que constitue la
création et la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires qui est une
question de choix de société un débat
public réel s'impose avec la vraie
question de du choix du nucléaire et pas
seulement des futurs installations sur
certains sites prédestinés donc ce grand
débat à la mesure de ce que représente
ce choix stratégique et politique cela
reste pour moi le premier impératif je
voudrais rappeler que les problématiques
posées par les réacteurs actuels ne sont
toujours pas résolus après plusieurs
dizaines d'années de fonctionnement en
premier on l'a dit les déchets
radioactifs toujours stockés en surface
et proche de la saturation en attente
d'un stockage de longue durée à Bures
s'ajoute le réchauffement climatique
cela a été évoqué avec le besoin d'eau
le ce que nous subissons actuellement
sécheresse diminution des quantités
d'eau et fermetures de certaines
centrales comme celle de Golfech sur la
Garonne or il faut de l'eau c'est un
impératif absolu pour refroidir une
centrale et enfin le risque ultime
d'accident qui est toujours réel
toujours possible et si on peut être
reconnaissant à EDF à la scène à l'IFN
de la bonne gestion de la sûreté
nucléaire nous ne sommes à l'abri de
rien on peut le mesurer au vu de
l'actualité à bien des écarts
préoccupantes s'agissant à la fois de
géopolitique mais aussi d'événements
extrêmes amenés à se multiplier donc je
rappelle que nous devons dans ce choix
associé les Français cela me paraît
absolument nécessaire merci
chers collègues Monsieur Jacques
vernique oui merci madame la Présidente
Fessenheim aurait été exécuté c'est
l'expression que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure alors à tous ceux qui répètent
en boucle que la fermeture de Fessenheim
aurait été une terrible erreur attentant
gravement souveraineté énergétique je
voudrais juste leur quelques éléments
ces deux réacteurs n'étaient
manifestement pas en mesure de passer
leur quatrième visite décennale qui
aurait dû intervenir en 2020 pour l'un
et en 2022 pour l'autre l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire c'est pas moi c'est
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire avait
imposé en 2012 la mise en place de
diesel d'ultime secours pour 2018 EDF
avait commencé mais a pris beaucoup de
retard la SN a donc accordé un délai
supplémentaire mais sous prétexte de
fermeture de la centrale EDF a refusé
cette prescription le renforcement du
radier rend séparant les réacteurs de la
nappe freddique avait été très
insuffisant cette amélioration
permettait de ralentir la traversée du
corium mais pas de l'arrêter rappelons
que l'épaisseur du radier avant
Fukushima était de 1m20 tandis que pour
la moyenne des autres centrales il est
de 4 mètres et pour Fukushima du 8
mètres l'ASN compte tenu d'un éruption
d'une amélioration même limitée à
autoriser la poursuite de l'exploitation
jusqu'à la fin de la vie des trois mais
ça n'avez pas été le cas pour la visite
décennale 4 enfin la falsification aux
ateliers du Creusot pour faire passer
des aciers non conformes on se rappelle
des fameux dossiers barrés à toucher de
nombreux centrales à Fessenheim la vie
rôle qu'il avait fallu remplacer sur le
générateur de vapeur 335 qui a quand
même provoqué 666 jours d'arrêt était
elle-même encore incorrecte cela avait
amené l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire à
l'autoriser à titre transitoire le
fonctionnement du réacteur 2 qu'en mode
dégradé et seulement pour la V3 encore
une fois la vie des quatre n'aurait pas
pu passer ces deux réacteurs détenaient
le triste record du nombre d'incidents
sur l'ensemble des centrales françaises
leurs production s'avérait
particulièrement intermittente en clair
ils étaient en fin de vie et par
pragmatisme les investissements pour se
hisser au niveau requis de la vedette
n'avait pas été jugé possible merci
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre Richard collègue bon dans ce
titre premier on avait déposé deux trois
amendements qui ont été déclarés et
recevables sur la question du statut des
salariés parce que notre collègue
centriste a eu raison tout à l'heure si
on donne un signal clair qu'on veut
refaire du nucléaire il va falloir de
l'attractivité pour attirer les talents
et oui et il va falloir construire les
filières formation et pour l'instant le
signal qu'on envoyait depuis 10 ans
c'est à nos meilleurs ingénieurs à nos
meilleures techniciens nos meilleurs
soudeurs venez plus dans le nucléaire on
en fabriquera plus et un des éléments
d'attractivité et je sais qu'on peut
avoir en débat entre nous c'est aussi le
statut et c'est aussi le statut
aujourd'hui de la sous-traitance parce
qu'une des questions du retard de le
père de Flamanville pas les procédures
administratives c'est la construction et
quand on discute
avec les ingénieurs avec les syndicats
et y compris avec des responsables d'EDF
il nous disent que la question la
sous-traitance elle est posée en grand
et donc là je sais que vous et vertuez à
casser les statuts on vous l'avait dit
par exemple en 2018 sur les cheminots
vous allez avoir un problème ça coûtera
plus cher et il y aura personne qui
voudra venir discuter à Monsieur farando
aujourd'hui il vous dira que les
concours de recrutement sont ouverts il
y a peu de candidats la RATP pareil
discutez avec Monsieur Castex il vient
d'ailleurs donner une belle conférence
de presse mille des missions l'an
dernier ben voilà un des trucs de
attractivité c'est la question du statut
parce qu'on paye moins cher mais oui il
y a la sécurité sur du long terme et
donc de ne pas vouloir parler de cette
question de la formation et du statut
des salariés de plein droit comme celui
des sous-traitants va poser problème et
vous ne relancerez pas du nucléaire
lourd sans salariés extrêmement bien
formés et sous statut je vous remercie
madame la Présidente merci Monsieur
Daniel salmon
merci madame la Présidente bon je sais
la mode est souvent aujourd'hui à la
réécriture de l'histoire c'est pour ça
que je vais prendre quelques instants
pour vous faire une petite histoire du
nucléaire français tout simplement on
décide de faire un parc nucléaire dans
les années 70 massif on a comme
hypothèse que on va consommer 1000
térawattheure d'électricité en l'an 2000
donc on y va
fortement il s'avère que et bien non on
ne va pas du tout chercher 1000
terawater mais il faut quand même
entretenir cette filière nucléaire
française donc on continue de construire
le dernier réacteur est construit et va
être livré en 2002 c'est si beau
il fonctionne pas du tout donc
effectivement on peut refaire l'histoire
réinventer trouver des fautes ici et là
mais il faut regarder un peu les choses
en face je continuerai la deuxième
partie de l'histoire plus tard
d'abord pour rebondir sur le propos
Justin à l'instant et ce qui était
oublié de d'être mentionné dans les
disques dans la discussion générale par
votre groupe il faut faire la
distinction entre EPR et EPR 2 c'est
justement parce que il a été constaté
des plus que les défaillances sur le la
construction de l'EPR sur la
construction même sur le le design de ce
de ce réacteur que les partenaires se
sont engagés sur un autre type de
réacteur le PR2 simplifier et tout le
monde est d'accord là-dessus normalement
ce serait bien de d'avoir des propos un
peu un petit peu plus exact dans vos
dans vos discussions après je voudrais
dire sur le diagnostic moi j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure monsieur Fanny et je me
dis qu'on a un formidable levier
d'économie en fait sur les visites des
céréales puisque les visites décennales
sont prévues ça c'est prévu dans les
textes tous les 10 ans chaque réacteur
fait l'objet d'une visite décennale pour
dire si oui ou non le réacteur est
encore en capacité de fonctionner pour
les 10 ça c'est la ça c'est la loi c'est
c'est fixé dans la loi et on nous dit en
fait on sait à l'avance qu'une visite
décennale ne va pas être validée que le
réacteur ne va pas être validé mais on a
une formidable levier d'économie l'IRL
la SN sont finalement des autorités dont
on peut se passer si on vous entend il
faut être un tout petit peu sérieux
justement l'objet d'une visite décennale
a du sens il faut aller jusqu'au bout de
la démarche et c'est cette visite qui
doit
discerner si les difficultés que vous
avez pointé sont susceptibles de mettre
à l'arrêt sur le réacteur mais moi j'ai
les voyants les voyants verts j'allais
dire les boules les boules de cristal
donc vous disposez je serais curieux de
de les tester parce que c'est absolument
pas là encore une vérité en tout cas
scientifique donc laissons faire les
autorités compétentes il peut y avoir
des des choses à regarder de près mais
laissons faire les autorités compétentes
qui sont payées pour ça
merci Monsieur Ronan dans tech
oui on rêve effectivement d'un débat un
peu structuré avec des vrais chiffres ce
qu'a dit Jacques fernix c'est les
positions de la SN c'est pas la boule de
cristal la cristal c'est ceux qui
pensent qu'on peut commencer à couler du
béton sur le design de le PR2 alors
qu'on l'a pas encore parce que il y a
quand même ça dans le dans la discussion
nous engageons on veut accélérer sur les
autorisations de travaux sur le génie
civil mais le PR2 ni vous ni moi ne
savait à quoi il ressemble on sait juste
que le père 1 c'est trop cher et ça
marche pas c'est ça la réalité et ça
marche pas mieux enfin Landes où il y en
a encore un à l'arrêt là ces derniers
jours et en Chine il y a déjà de vrai
problème la réalité c'est ce qu'a dit
Henri Proglio mais écoutez Henri Proglio
défenseur d'EDF et du EDF d'avant Henri
Proglio a dit de manière extrêmement
claire tout en étant très très peu
favorable au développement des honneurs
le Pr est une vraie connerie il a dit
devant l'Assemblée nationale c'est trop
compliqué c'est trop cher ça ne marche
pas c'est ça une partie du débat que
nous avons et le débat que nous devons
avoir sur la loi de programmation c'est
là dessus c'est à dire que nous sommes
en train de prendre un risque économique
absolu c'est un parieur c'est la boule
de cristal plus plus sur le fait que
nous n'avons jamais démontré qu'il y a
dans le monde tel qu'il est un seul
retour possible économique sur le prix
du mégaeth produit par le PR2 les zones
ne s'y trompent pas puisque les rares
pays qui vont dans le nucléaire achètent
russe ou américain mais n'achète pas le
Pr parce que en plus ils ont lu Proglio
ils risquent pas de l'acheter donc on
est dans cette situation donc vous êtes
je suis désolé mais c'est un vœu absolu
la relance du nucléaire sur ses bases et
c'est un risque de marginalisation de
l'économie française et le débat qu'on
aura sur la loi de programmation c'est
ça est-ce que l'économie française
survivra au coût du mégawattheure en
2040 produit par ce genre de machine qui
ne marche pas
merci chers collègues alors nous allons
examiner deux amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune sont
identiques et ce sont des amendements de
suppression le 42 monsieur salmon
merci madame la Présidente la définition
d'une nouvelle stratégie énergétique
nationale du nucléaire n'a pas sa place
dans ce texte de loi ce texte ne porte
pas sur la place du nucléaire dans le
mix énergétique et c'est la future loi
quinquennale de programmation sur
l'énergie et le climat qui devra
notamment accès ou non la relance du
programme nucléaire national je ne vous
apprendrai normalement rien sur le sujet
actez ainsi de manière cavalière
unilatérale et anti-démocratique le
remplacement de l'objectif de réduction
de 50% d'énergie nucléaire d'ici 2035
par un objectif de maintien à 50% au
moins à l'horizon 2050 pour relancer la
filière nucléaire ou encore
l'introduction d'un objectif de
production d'énergie nucléaire à partir
de matières recyclées 20% d'ici 2030
pour valoriser le cycle de contenution
de combustible n'est pas opportun alors
que le débat plus vite public sur les
oper2 est en cours et ce jusqu'à fin
février et que la concertation publique
sur le mix énergétique n'a pas encore
lieu ces nouveaux objectifs sont de
manière prématurée toutes les garanties
doivent être apportées pour que ces
choix politiques soient pris dans le
respect du Parlement et de ne
concitoyens mais cela à l'aide à n'a pas
l'air d'être facile avec le nucléaire ça
ne doit pas être décidé unilatéralement
et en catimini c'est pourquoi il est
demandé la suppression de cet article
merci merci l'amendement 54 monsieur
mangez
chers collègues ce que je veux dire
vaudra pour le 54 55 et le 58 je vais
pas reprendre ce que j'ai dit en
discussion générale et que d'autres
groupes ont également exprimé je
voudrais
simplement
rappeler l'enjeu
démocratique qui est lié à la à la
possibilité
que les Français s'expriment sur la
question de la politique énergétique de
leur pays c'est une exigence
constitutionnelle puisque elle est
inscrite dans la Charte de
l'environnement depuis 2004 et je pense
que le ce que nous faisons en
introduisant dans ce texte initialement
prévu pour pour les procédures ce que
nous faisons en intégrant une partie du
débat sur la sur la PPE en particulier
n'est pas n'est pas bon ne donne pas une
bonne image de fonctionnement de notre
Parlement aux Français il y a des gauche
consultation que ça a été dit qui sont
engagés
consultation sur la stratégie française
énergique Clément consultation également
enquête publique sur les six EPR qui
sont qui sont annoncés
voilà je pense qu'il faut se laisser les
choses se dérouler que nous prenions en
compte le fruit de ces débats de
l'expression des Français qui se seront
positionnés sur ces sujets avant de
légiférer en 2023 comme cela est prévu
voilà on mélange tout je pense pas que
ça soit de nature à clarifier le débat
pourtant fondamental qui concerne qui
concerne les les Français et je redis
que je regrette que le Président de la
République est pris tout seul cette
décision sans considération en
particulier des positions du Parlement à
cet égard voilà j'ai compris qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
aller vite aller vite mais on peut pas
le faire n'importe comment et encore une
fois on mélange tout et c'est pas bon
pour la compréhension des Français on a
besoin d'embarquer les Français sur sur
les questions et les enjeux de ces
politiques énergétiques merci
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
les deux abonnements 42 et 54 qui sont
identiques visent à supprimer l'article
première abrogeant plusieurs
dispositions du code de l'énergie par
coordination avec la relance du
nucléaire poursuivi par le projet de loi
et je rappelle que l'article 1er a
constitué un apport majeur de notre
commission pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que contenu de la relance
du nucléaire annoncé c'est notre
commission en effet souhaité revenir sur
les verrous issus de la loi de
transition énergétique de 2015 d'une
part sur l'objectif des 50 pans pour
cent pour 2035
je vous rappelle que si le Sénat n'avait
pas été là
on était à 2025
je le rappelle parce que tout le monde
fait abstraction de de ces événements si
le Sénat n'avait pas été là la PPE
n'était même pas discuté au Parlement
c'est nous c'est votre serviteur mais
c'est puisque c'est vous qui avez voté
les amendements c'est le Sénat qui a été
à l'origine du débat parlementaire sur
la PPE et c'est nous qui avons eu la
capacité de garder au niveau des
discussions dans la CMP je dis quand
même en passant parce que quand
j'entends l'absence de débat
démocratique je pense que là c'est une
belle leçon démocratie que nous avons
ramenée sur le départ parlementaire je
le dis quand même il faut le reconnaître
personne ne le dit je reviens sur
l'autre objet quand même
il y a eu un travail qui a été fait au
niveau de la commission je parle sous le
contrôle de notre président de la
commission des affaires économiques il y
a eu un travail transpartisan qui a été
réalisé
et ce rapport qu'est-ce qu'il dit il dit
relance le nucléaire et il dit nécessité
aussi d'avoir un couplage une réflexion
nucléaire hydrogène donc je le dis parce
que quand on revient sur le 50 % et
cette édit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui et madame la ministre vous
l'avez dit vous-même
aujourd'hui on est encore à 70%
d'énergie qui proviennent du nucléaire
donc comment voulez-vous relancer
une capacité de production pour notre
pays au niveau de l'énergie pilotable si
vous n'avez une affirmez pas
effectivement ces choses donc c'est un
avis défavorable sur leur manquement 42
et 54
merci gouvernement madame la ministre
oui alors je veux redire que
mathématiquement et ça c'est les
scénarios RTE même en construisant 14
réacteurs nucléaires à horizon 2050 je
me plaçais horizon 2050 dans le meilleur
des scénarios ça a été rappelé et c'est
les mathématiques c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment on peut se faire plaisir
politiquement mais il y a quand même la
réalité physique qui nous rattrape le
maximum de la part du nucléaire c'est
50%. je le rappelle dans ces scénarios
de RTE donc ça doit nous faire réfléchir
collectivement par rapport à la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
qui est à venir pour rebondir sur
d'abord juste pour répondre très
rapidement à Madame la signatrice qui
posait une question sur le Technocentre
de DF je veux juste vous rappeler
qu'effectivement ce projet n'est pas du
tout à l'arrêt puisque EDF doit nous
présenter le programme l'aide est prévue
elle est réservée dans le cadre du plan
de relance elle est bien financée et des
projets industriels sont en cours de
finalisation sur le site de fines et
Monsieur gay sur la formation vous le
savez il y a un le premier programme qui
a été je rappelle que le premier
programme de lancer par mes sphères
auquel nous faisons tous référence 56
réacteurs a été construit par le monde
industriel qui s'off erreur n'était pas
sous statut sur la partie construction
génie civile cuve pièce diverses
tuyauterie etc n'oublions pas ce détail
donc en fait on a su faire son statut
voilà ce qui n'enlève rien à la question
du statut mais on a su le faire sans
statut pour une grosse partie des
constructeurs ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'elle attractivité quelle
formation comment on fait évoluer les
filières et c'est un point qui est une
indéfacteurs clés de succès potentiel ou
pas ou des ou des chèques du programme
nouveau nucléaire et je vous rejoins sur
ça
voilà et sur monsieur salmon vous
demandiez
pour enfin nous avons un voilà je vous
au top un EPR qui n'a pas au rendez-vous
exactement et Monsieur Dantec de ce
qu'il devait être je rappelle et ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont les
donc vous avez interrogé dans le cadre
de la mission d'enquête qui indique pour
avoir un programme industriel il faut
plusieurs réacteurs
[Musique]
la facilité utile ou pas mais ce sont
des programmes et des réalisations
industrielles exceptionnelles qu'on a
porté et avec efficacité et qu'on
continue à porter dans d'autres filières
donc voilà maintenant il faut prendre
les bons moyens pour faire pour revenir
maintenant à cet amendement deux choses
moi je ne reviendrai pas sur la
suppression du plafond de 63 gigawatts
puisque effectivement nous travaillons à
préparer
une proposition de relance du programme
nucléaire nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui
en capacité ça sera le propos de la PPE
de fixer le plafond mais si
effectivement il faut envoyer un signal
à cette filière en voyant le en disant
c'est une question qui est posée la
position du gouvernement elle est très
claire c'est d'augmenter
la comment dire la part de nucléaire en
valeur absolue dans notre mix
énergétique s'il s'agit maintenant de
dire quelle est la proportion ça c'est
une discussion qui suppose d'inviter les
énergies renouvelables à la table et
c'est parce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
et donc par rapport à vos amendements
et je rejoins votre atamisme monsieur le
sénateur montoger que la PPE c'est une
discussion qui doit prendre en compte
l'ensemble des éléments quel
consommation quelle baisse de
consommation en cible quelle
augmentation de production des énergies
renouvelables qu'elle augmentation des
énergies nu avec probablement différents
scénarios possibles sur lesquels vous
vous positionnerez et sur lequel nous
ferons des propositions très claires
mais d'ici là je c'est une demande de
retrait au profit de l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui
enlèvera enfin laissera le plafond qui a
été enlevé par la commission
développant durable ou à faire
économique enfin à faire économique
pardon ne reviendra pas sur ce plafond
mais effectivement proposera d'ajuster
l'objectif en tenant compte de la
diversification du mix électrique afin
de dire que nous avons besoin de deux
jambes une jambe énergie renouvelable
une jambe nucléaire c'est le message que
nous envoyons aux deux filières et le
pourcentage ça sera à la PPE de le
définir ainsi que les valeurs absolues
de production énergétique et puissance
que nous souhaitons avoir dans les 10
filières les différentes filières
technologiques donc demande de retrait
au profil amendement 118 mais si
Monsieur Breuillet
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues bon d'abord une
remarque sur votre réponse madame la
ministre Flamanville a dérapé mais les
oper2 ça ira bien il suffit d'y croire
j'espère aussi d'y travailler mais
malgré tout il y a un peu de croyance
dans cette idée que le premier repère 2
ce portera bien quand le premier EPM
n'est toujours pas en fonction mais
madame la ministre voulait vous
interroger vous venez donner votre
demande de retrait de ces deux
amendements et je vous avoue que vous
m'avez perdu vous dites ce texte ne doit
pas être l'objet de discussion de la PPE
qui viendra il faut respecter les
procédures démocratiques mais ensuite
vous dites bon d'accord on revient pas
sur les 63 mais quand même on peut
rediscuter du mix énergétique donc soit
on discute de la PPE et de la proportion
du mix énergétique soit on en discute
pas si on en discute pas je pense que
les amendements de nos collègues
seulement et monte Auger ont toutes
leurs places et que ça permet que ce
texte choix effectivement celui que vous
avez présenté de débattre des procédures
d'accélération et pas du mix énergétique
monsieur Dantec
oui j'avoue que je suis effectivement
moi aussi un peu perdu tout en
rejoignant le rapporteur Daniel grimier
sur le fait que le Sénat a effectivement
investi pour qu'il y a un vrai débat
démocratique et de planification sur la
sur la PPE y compris je rappelle que
Daniel grimier défendait 50 gigawatts
installé en production d'éolien offshore
ce qui est totalement incompatible parce
que certains sur les bancs de LR
proposés en les installant de l'autre
côté du Chanel mais au-delà de ça la PPE
je pense que je la connais un peu
puisqu'il se trouve que c'est le groupe
écolo de l'époque qui a négocié la
dernière nuit avant la présentation de
la loi royale la durée de la PPE avec le
cabinet de Manuel Valls c'était un
élément du deal entre effectivement les
socialistes et les écolos donc je vous
donne des éléments dédiés qui ont été
passés à l'époque et que nous avons à
l'époque
et nous avons à l'époque c'est important
passer la PPE de 5 à 10 ans puisque
l'État nous proposait une PPE de 5 ans
ce qui était un peu n'importe quoi
puisqu'on est sur des temps de
planification plus longs mais
aujourd'hui la PBL est quand même de 10
ans donc là on parle de bécane qui ne
fonctionne pas dans les 10 ans donc
pourquoi on touche à la PPE maintenant
puisque c'est aucune de ces bécanes ne
seront dans les 10 ans les seuls les
seules choses qui peuvent changer la PPE
dans les 10 ans c'est le développement
comme la souligné madame la ministre un
marche forcée des énergies renouvelables
grâce à la loi sur les énergies
renouvelables donc si on change la PPE
c'est uniquement sur la part du
renouvelable puisque dans les 10 ans
c'est la seule part qui peut monter plus
vite donc je ne comprends pas bien la
logique effectivement de cet article je
suis un peu perdu et en quelques
secondes puisque j'adore le débogue nous
avons cet après-midi on est quand même
au niveau industriel dans le seul cas où
le prototype ne marche pas et on lance
la série quand même sans essayer de voir
pourquoi le prototype ne marche pas et
attendre qu'il marche un peu avant de
lancer une série
quand même c'est quand même une
nouveauté industrielle comme on en avait
rarement connu c'est quand même un peu
risqué industriellement me semble-t-il
merci merci madame la Présidente nous on
souhaite revenir au texte initial
c'est-à-dire un texte qui soit un texte
d'accélération qui comporte donc un
certain nombre d'aspects je l'ai déjà
souligné qui soit des aspects à la fois
administratifs et juridique mais quand
on lit quand on lit cet article 1 à
nouveau qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit il nous
dit la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie fait l'objet d'une révision
simplifiée destinée à la mettre en
conformité avec la construction avec les
constructions de réacteurs
électronucléaires ou leur prolongation
poursuivi notamment par cette loi ça
veut dire qu'on est dans la version du
processus ça veut dire que la ppee doit
s'adapter à la loi d'accélération que
l'on va voter ou qu'on votera pas dans
les quelques instants dans les dans les
dans les heures qui vont suivre donc si
on veut véritablement à ce qu'il y ait
un débat serein laissons le débat se
déroulait tous les éléments chacun
pourra se positionner et moi j'ai je
dirais au sens propre comme au sens
figuré beaucoup d'atomes cro avec Daniel
grémillier et moi je suis je suis je
suis un partisan du développement de la
filière électronucléaire sous certaines
conditions et je regarde Fabien gay
droit dans les yeux parce que je crois
qu'on partage un certain nombre de
points communs là-dessus le nucléaire je
pense personnellement que nous en avons
besoin mais pas de n'importe quel
nucléaire un nucléaire qui soit
nucléaire responsable donc à partir de
ce moment-là donc nous sommes nous pour
le retour à au texte initial tel qu'il
était proposé et puis les sons la PPE se
déroulait sereinement et une décondition
de la sérénité justement c'est de ne pas
mettre la pression sur le débat et
d'imposer par ce projet de loi déjà des
décisions qui doivent être prises
ultérieurement je profite des quelques
secondes qui restent pour corriger une
erreur le réacteur finlandais de le
kilou auto 3 est à l'acte actuellement à
l'arrêt non pas pour des questions
nucléaires mais pour des questions de
défaillance au niveau de l'îlothurbine
et alternateur donc on aura une
chaufferie à une chaufferie charbon
devant le problème sera le même donc je
sais pas du tout un incident nucléaire
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre vous avez conclu la discussion
générale en disant et en répondant aux
critiques qui émanent de la totalité de
ses bancs sur le fait qu'on prend le
débat enfin que vous nous obliger à
prendre le débat en dépit du bon sens en
nous jurant les grands dieux si je peux
le dire ainsi que tout allait
parfaitement dans le bon ordre et là
vous venez de nous dire qu'il fallait
marcher sur nos deux jambes le nucléaire
et les énergies renouvelables ce qui
nous renforce dans notre conviction que
peut-être il aurait fallu aborder la PPE
en premier et puis peut-être même qu'il
aurait fallu un texte global qui nous
permettent d'examiner
la production énergétique donc dont nous
avons besoin dans sa globalité parce que
la manière dont vous souciez de sonner
les choses conduit chacun
je dirais y compris à son corps
défendant
aborder le débat sous un angle presque
idéologique or si nous avons besoin d'un
mix énergétique ça n'est pas d'abord
pour des raisons idéologiques c'est
d'abord pour répondre à des besoins
divers auxquels aucune source et aucune
aucun mode de production ne peut
répondre à lui seul et c'est pour ça
qu'on a besoin de diversifier donc
vraiment les choses sont ainsi engagées
mais il me semble qu'on commencerait le
débat sous de meilleures hospices si
vous acceptiez d'entendre madame la
ministre qu'il aurait mieux valu prendre
les choses dans un ordre différent merci
merci Monsieur Montauger
merci madame la Présidente
j'écoute attentivement et j'ai
l'impression parfois qu'on se qu'on se
berce de mots je voudrais poser une
question à Madame la Ministre on est
aujourd'hui donc à 63,2 gigawatts
autorisé
qu'elles vont être madame la ministre si
vous les connaissez je pense que vous
avez des informations en ce sens les
effets de grand carénage qui va qui va
conduire effectivement à l'arrêt de
réacteur pour des raisons techniques sur
la base des demandes de l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire voilà donc c'est quand
même pas neutre par rapport à la
question de ces de ces amendements je
voudrais aussi dire ça a été ça a été
rappelé que la PPE nouvelle version va
arriver très très rapidement donc ça
revient effectivement à donner un signe
à la filière pourquoi pas
et je voudrais attirer votre attention
sur le scénario dit de mix équilibré
comme comme vous de RTE le n03
voilà qui prévoit quand même un seuil à
51 gigawatts concernant le nucléaire
avec 27 de nucléaires existants et le
complément à 51 correspondant à du
nucléaire nouveau qui ne sera pas
d'ailleurs couvert intégralement par les
6 plus 8 qui sont qui sont annoncés
aujourd'hui par le par le président donc
voilà on est dans ce contexte là qui est
qui est pour moi pas très très clair et
je rajoute à cela je terminerai
là-dessus que et on le vit sur nos
territoires moi je suis très très
inquiet des difficultés à planifier le
développement des énergies renouvelables
photovoltaïques et aux liens éolien
terrestre voire méthanisation
on a vraiment des difficultés à
développer tout ça et je rappelle que le
scénario RTE le plus avait la plus forte
proportion de NR prévoit quand même pour
le photovoltaïque une multiplication par
7 et pour l'éolienne terrestre par on
est on est loin du compte par rapport à
ce qui se dessine et aux difficultés
qu'on rencontre sur le terrain ça pose
la question de l'efficacité de la
planification
mais il faut respecter son temps
monsieur gay
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues mais vous
voyez madame la ministre dans votre
introduction générale qui a duré 11
minutes 40 secondes vous avez passé 8
minutes à nous expliquer qu'est-ce qu'il
n'y avait pas dans le texte et de quoi
il fallait pas parler et trois minutes
pour nous dire voilà de quoi il faut
parler et patatras article 1er a ben
nous sommes dans cette contradiction
c'est que votre texte arrive avant la
PPE et ce n'est pas possible et les
amendements présentés par mes collègues
ils ont justement raison on ne peut pas
débattre
sérieusement sur la question nucléaire
ça a d’avoir défini une stratégie quel
mix électrique etc etc et après on aura
des débats et peut-être des désaccords
et des divergences mais une fois qu'on
aura tranché ça et à l'inverse le
rapporteur a tout à fait raison d'avoir
mis
cela dans l'article premier rang
parce qu'autrement on débat d'un texte
non mais je comprends non mais je
comprends les deux positions où on veut
accélérer et il y a encore la fermeture
des 12 réacteurs prévus plus personne ne
comprend rien mais madame la ministre je
vous dis la situation dans laquelle on
est ce n'est que votre faute c'est ne
que la façon dont vous avez voulu
prendre ce débat et sur les quatre
amendements notre position
parce que je pense que sur le fond on
sera d'accord émission rapporteur mais
on s'absiendra sur tous ces amendements
parce que de toute façon vous prenez et
vous avez voulu prendre je ne sais
toujours pas pourquoi le débat dans ce
sens-là vous n'allez rien accélérer du
tout je vous le dis sérieusement sans
avoir un débat de fond je vous remercie
je reste comme depuis le début dans les
deux minutes vous êtes parfait monsieur
gay je vais mettre aux voix donc les
deux amendements identiques 42 et 54 qui
ont reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ne sont
donc pas adoptés l'amendement 118
présentée par même la ministre pour le
gouvernement
donc c'est tellement dement vise à
revenir sur la suppression de l'objectif
de 50% de production d'origine nucléaire
dans le mix et l'énergétique qui a été
introduit par la Commission dans ces
débats et à rappeler qu'il que la PPE
vise à diversifier le mix énergétique en
visant un meilleur équilibre entre le
nucléaire et les énergies renouvelables
ils ne préampe pas comme je l'ai entendu
il ne préampe pas le débat de la PPE il
respecte justement ce qui est la demande
je crois de beaucoup de sénateurs ici de
dire on ne fait pas le débat sur la PPE
j'entends aussi que tout le monde en a
plein la bouche de la concertation du
public sauf qu'aujourd'hui ce que vous
êtes en train de nous demander c'est
d'écraser le débat public le débat
public il est en cours il est en cours
en ce moment il a des barres il a
démarré au mois d'octobre il y a une
convention avec des jeunes de 18 à 35
ans qui visent à finaliser ce débat
public qui se déroule maintenant qui se
déroule maintenant auquel d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d'entre vous sont invités
il y a des recommandations qui ont été
formulées par la Commission nationale du
débat public que nous appliquons
strictement précisément pour avoir cet
exercice au moment démocratique où nous
associons l'ensemble des Français à la
définition d'un pix énergétique est-ce
que vous êtes en train de nous dire
c'est qu'il faut écraser ce débat moi je
pense que c'est pas une bonne idée et je
ne foulerai pas la concertation publique
pour
faire la PPE et donc si on le respecte
alors la loi sur la PPE elle arrive dans
les mois qui viennent elle n'arrive pas
avant la fin du débat public et par
ailleurs et j'ai le regret de le dire
gouverner c'est anticipé
gouverner c'est anticipé d'ailleurs vous
avez suffisamment reproché au
gouvernement de pas anticiper donc
laissez-nous anticiper sur les
procédures administratives qui demandent
des mois de travail et c'est pas nous
qui faisons la demande c'est EDF qui
fait la demande c'est la SN qui fait qui
fait la demande d'avoir aujourd'hui une
loi d'accélération des procédures
administratives pour être prêt quand on
veut être à la PPE c'est une demande de
la filière et nous faisons notre travail
d'anticiper donc effectivement je crois
que tout le monde a intérêt à sortir de
la posture politique parce que la
responsabilité que nous avons c'est
construire cette fameuse indépendance
énergétique donc je le regrette dire
qu'elle n'a pas existé depuis la fin de
la deuxième guerre mondiale
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
oui madame la présente
je vais pas redire ce que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure sur les amendements
précédents
mais madame Lamy je comprends pas vous
faites une partie du chemin mais
pourquoi vous ne reprenez pas le travail
qui a été fait au niveau de la
commission des affaires économiques qui
qui va jusqu'au bout qui a le courage
d'aller jusqu'au bout pour deux raisons
vous ne trouverez pas et on le sait tous
qu'on a perdu les compétences vous ne
trouverez pas une filière qui va
s'engager au niveau vous ne trouverez
pas de jeunes qui vont s'engager dans
les métiers ou effectivement nous avons
perdu les compétences si vous donnez pas
un signe et surtout une trajectoire non
pas à court terme mais avec une vision
le rôle du gouvernement le rôle des
parlementaire c'est d'avoir une vision
d'avoir une stratégie pour les pays et
je partage ce que vous avez dit notre
position qui a été votée en commission
des affaires économiques n'est pas
l'hypothèque pas du tout la stratégie de
la PPE pas du tout vous l'avez vous-même
évoqué tout à l'heure objectif 2050 on a
28 réacteurs pour lesquels il y aura des
décisions soit de prolongation si la SN
et si c'est compatible avec la sécurité
soit effectivement de renouvellement et
c'est tout le questionnement qui aura au
niveau de la PPE mais je vais plus loin
madame la ministre
aujourd'hui on sait tous que la bataille
de l'hydrogène est en train de se jouer
à travers le monde et qu'elle est en
train de se jouer tout près de nous en
Europe notamment avec les Allemands et
on sait tous que si on ne donne pas un
signe notamment sur le nucléaire nous
n'aurons pas de recherche de n'aurons
pas d'innovation d'électrolyseur à haute
température qui apporte les meilleurs
rendements en termes de production
d'hydrogène c'est tous ces enjeux là
qu'on a posé à travers la commission
économique sur les amendements les
articles additionnels que nous avons
présenté donc c'est un avis défavorable
merci Monsieur
le GAT oui
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre c'est amendement est
complètement en contradiction avec les
propos liminaires que vous avez tenus
tout à l'heure parce que vous nous avez
dit et le compte-rendu fera foi ni la
place du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique sera remis en cause ce n'est
pas un texte de programmation
énergétique voilà ce que vous avez
déclaré tout à l'heure or l'amendement
que vous nous proposez et dans le texte
initial d'ailleurs quand on s'y réfère
le texte initial modifie au moins une
quinzaine de fois le code de l'urbanisme
une dizaine de fois le code dans
l'environnement le Code de la Propriété
le code des impôts le code de
l'ex-propriation en aucun cas je vous
mets au défi de trouver une modification
du code de l'énergie parce que vous
étiez resté entre guillemets dans votre
couloir de celui d'une feuille de route
et là je suis désolé mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on est en sortie de
route et qu'on est même parti dans le
décor parce que modifier le code de
l'énergie une certaine façon et bien
c'est à travers la suppression de cet
article 5
dit quoi il dit réduire la part du
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité à 50% à l'horizon 2035
2035 sinon 12 ans donc on a le temps on
a le temps de modifier il faudra la
modifier il faudra modifier ce code de
l'énergie on a le temps justement de
respecter
les qui sont en train de se dérouler en
ce moment et nous n'écrasons pas au
contraire nous voulons renforcer le
débat public nous voulons que le débat
public se fasse dans la dans la sérénité
et pour que le débat public se fasse
dans la sérénité et bien ne bordons pas
par des injonctions se débat public en
disant vous pouvez débattre mais on a
déjà nous par le Parlement on a déjà
décidé de modifier la PPE ça me paraît
moi et je lui dis tout à l'heure un déni
de démocratie participative
merci Monsieur longuet
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègue franchement je
remercie la Commission et son rapporteur
Daniel grenier d'avoir ouvert enfin
d'une façon qui oblige à la rationalité
un débat qui va durer plusieurs mois et
qui sera Infiné tranchée par le
législateur quel mixte énergétique
acceptons-nous au plus précisément sur
quel principe doivent se fonder les
investissements qui permettront à notre
pays d'avoir de l'énergie
le débat public par la commission
nationale très bien qui peut croire un
seul instant que de se débat public
puisse rejaillir des
éléments suffisamment précis et
rigoureux je prends l'exemple
l'hydrogène pour décarboner l'industrie
si c'est une priorité ce sont plusieurs
gigawatts qu'il faut installer pour la
seule sidérurgie ou pour par exemple la
chimie et les activités pétrolières si
l'on veut gérer des données et savoir
jusqu'où la consommation de numérique
ira il faut également donner les moyens
d'une électricité parfaitement maitrisée
qui ne peut supporter ni les
intermittences ni les variations de
fréquence par exemple nous avons sur la
mobilité
légère ou sur la mobilité avec des
batteries ou sur la mobilité lourde avec
l'hydrogène des Caps des besoins
considérables qu'il faut évaluer nous
avons en face de cela de coups de CAPEX
avec des technologies qui changent moi
je veux bien qu'un débat public nous
disent qu'elle doit être le mix
énergétique nous permettez-moi de ne pas
prendre aux sérieux ce type de travaux
en revanche en ouvrant aujourd'hui et
publiquement avec le soutien de ceux qui
proposent le texte de la commission et
avec l'apport
utile de ceux qui le combattent nous
avons un débat qui obligera les
responsables français compétents
apprendre position c'est ce que je
voudrais c'est qu'il prenne position
merci sur des capacités effectives et
non pas sur des sentiments comme ah je
vois un mixte agréable
ok agréable c'est l'avenir de la France
moi chers collègues moi je vais vous
dire c'est deux minutes c'est pas deux
minutes de plus et c'est pour tout le
monde parce que tout à l'heure j'ai
laissé monsieur le rapporteur j'ai
laissé monsieur le rapporteur 20
secondes de plus j'ai eu des messages de
droite et de gauche d'ailleurs enfin
quand j'ai droit de gauche un peu
partout pour te dire oui oui si si pour
pour justement demander des temps
supplémentaires donc je vous remercie
d'éviter de dépasser votre temps je
pense qu'en deux minutes tout le monde
sait passer son message donc merci
beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente je vais donc
enlever 20 secondes que j'offre à
Monsieur Longuet je voulais dire et
redire que ce qu'a voulu faire la
commission des affaires économiques avec
cet article c'est de donner un signal
fort comme l'a dit madame la ministre
pour la relance de la filière nucléaire
ce signal fort il ne peut pas être juste
des mesures techniques il doit être des
mesures techniques pour accompagner la
création de six opère 2 et pour dire le
nucléaire a de l'avenir dans ce pays
pour les vins pour les 30 prochaines
années puisqu'on s'apprête à faire des
EPR pour ce pays je vous remercie madame
la ministre de dire que la voix choisie
parmi la commission des affaires
économiques ne vient pas se substituer à
la PPE que faisons-nous ici nous disons
juste le 50% est obsolète il n'est pas
cohérent avec cette mesure aujourd'hui
on nous propose dans le projet de loi de
création de nouveaux EPR nous le
retirons juste et nous faisons acte que
nous arrêtons la fermeture des 12
réacteurs supplémentaires en disant ça
nous ne prémontons pas le débat public
parce que les 50% ils pourront devenir
peut-être 75 et c'est peut-être la
préférence de ce côté-ci du de
l'hémicycle mais ils pourront peut-être
devenir vain et ça sera peut-être la
possibilité ici nous ne préomptons pas
nous simplement nous disons les 50%
c'est obsolète et nous accompagnons les
mesures techniques par une vision
politique
merci alors je mets aux voix donc
l'amendement 118 du gouvernement qui a
la ministre vous voulez parler oui
j'entends le débat mais il me semble que
c'est effectivement plutôt un débat qui
tourne autour de la place du nucléaire
je rappelle l'amendement du Gouvernement
qui est précisément en amendement qui
préserve la PPE et qui préserve toutes
les discussions à venir je lis il s'agit
de dire que la programmation
pluriannuelle doit avoir un objectif de
diversification du mix électrique en
visant un meilleur équilibre entre le
nucléaire et les énergies renouvelables
précisément elle pose le débat après
j'entends que ce débat ait lieu mais ne
prenez pas la partie le gouvernement
alors que nous tenons une ligne très
claire qui effectivement d'aller au bout
du débat public de même que nous tenons
une ligne très claire qui est de dire
que si on nous demande notre avis et ce
que nous proposerons au Parlement est
effectivement une relance de programme
nucléaire et que d'ores et déjà ne nous
y préparons je précise aussi une chose
monsieur le rapporteur on ne vous a pas
attendu pour relancer l'hydrogène bas
carbone les ipcei on a passé deux ans à
les négocier avec la commission europ et
on a aujourd'hui 15 projets qui sont
partis sur les électrolyseurs et je peux
vous assurer que ces dossiers sont sur
les rails et qu'ils sont très attractifs
y compris en termes de recrutement de
même que sur la formation on ne vous a
pas attendu non plus et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'opinion publique
est en train de bouger puisque
aujourd'hui alors qu'on avait des
difficultés à remplir les sections qui
avaient des spécialités nucléaires dans
les écoles d'ingénieurs aujourd'hui ces
sections sont plus demandées qu'il n'y a
pas de place l'enjeu que nous avons en
matière de formation c'est de descendre
ça jusqu'au compétences de Bac
Professionnel bac professionnel plus
deux ans c'est les compétences de
soudure les compétences
électrotechniciens d'électromécanicien
c'est toutes ces compétences et c'est
l'enjeu de remplacement des personnes
qui seront amenées à partir à la
retraite et d'ailleurs certaines
réformes peuvent nous y aider
merci alors donc je me vois l'amendement
118 du gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils ont
pas adopté l'amendement 14 me suis
seulement
merci madame le Président il est
nécessaire de rappeler le cadre normatif
dans lequel s'inscrit ce projet de loi
d'accélération du nucléaire nous sommes
lucides nous savons que compte tenu du
retard pris sur l'efficacité énergétique
et sur les renouvelables nous n'allons
pas pouvoir nous passer du nucléaire
existant tout de suite il nous faudra
plusieurs décennies pour nous en
affranchir mais il y a urgence à ne pas
relancer le nouveau nucléaire nous
souhaitons ainsi sécuriser le cas de
juridique en vigueur en rappelant que
tout projet de réacteur nucléaire
supplémentaire doit demeurer cohérent
avec le nécessaire mix énergétique ainsi
qu'avec l'obligation de réduction de la
part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité c'est le débat que nous
avons en ce moment nous ne partageons
pas votre vision qui demeure à l'article
l104 du code de l'énergie aujourd'hui
seule l'exploitant à la possibilité de
demander l'abrogation des autorisations
d'exploiter lorsque le plafond de 63,2
gigawatts et susceptible d'être dépassé
ce plafond a pour objectif uniquement
d'éviter une extension du parc nucléaire
et ne permet pas de remplir les
objectifs de réduction de la part du
nucléaire fixé par la loi ainsi en
dotant le ministre chargé de l'énergie
du pouvoir de fermeture des centrales du
nucléaires nous souhaitons aux éviter de
faire reposer entre les mains exclusives
de l'exploitant la possibilité d'abroger
des autorisations d'exploiter et
garantir le respect des objectifs de
décarbonation du mix et de réduction de
la part du nucléaire ce n'est pas à
l'exploitant de piloter la politique
énergétique française merci
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
s on n'a pas dit la même chose je
parlais des électrolyseurs aux
températures et vous m'expliquerez
comment vous en faites sans nucléaire
sur cet abonnement là je voulais dire
tout simplement c'est pour tirer un
trait sur cette politique d'attribution
du nucléaire que la Commission proposait
d'abroger ce plafonnement a priori de
63,2 gigawatts
si on va dans votre sens
c'est absolument pas souhaitable parce
que la rédaction telle que vous l'avez
rédigée en plus ça pourrait permettre de
remplacer de l'énergie nucléaire
décarbonée par des énergies fossiles
voire émissives donc la vie défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement
c'est également un avis défavorable
merci je vais donc mettre au voile à mon
manque 14 qui a reçu un avis défavorable
donc de la Commission du gouvernement
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient et donc pas adopté je mets au
voile article première qui est pour
contre qui s'abstient et donc adopté
[Musique]